[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 1er avril nouveau
mois nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal tout de suite les
titres chasseurs contre défenseurs des
animaux samedi la ville de rambouillet a
été le théâtre de deux manifestations
celle du collectif
havas abolissons la vénerie aujourd'hui
contre mobilisation des partisans de la
chasse à courre venu à défendre une
pratique ancestrale les deux cortèges ne
se sont pas croisés en ce début avril la
trêve hivernale prend fin les expulsions
coupures de gaz et d'électricité ne sont
plus suspendu situation préoccupante
pour les locataires concernés mais aussi
pour plusieurs campements de roms des
yvelines
invité de ce journal bernard au lion
responsable du secours catholique de
montigny le bretonneux
et puis il a démarré ce week-end le
deuxième festival rire soleil se tient
jusqu'au 11 mai cinq dates et une
dizaine d'humoristes et artistes au
programme un événement organisé par
l'association rire 78 et l'agglomération
versailles grand parc nous en parlons en
plateau avec nous également tout à
l'heure le journaliste laurent mansart
qui publie son premier polar mettez la
au parfum on en parle à la fin de ce
journal
samedi mouvementée donc à rambouillet la
ville était au coeur d'une double
manifestation pour ce jour de fermeture
de la saison de la chasse à courre
l'association ava abolissons la vénerie
aujourd'hui avait choisi de protester
contre cette pratique les chasseurs eux
aussi se sont rassemblés le récit de
mélanie poquet les uns à la gare les
autres au château à rambouillet ce
samedi de manifestation les pro et anti
chasse à courre c'est une pratique
cruelle qui consiste à traquer un animal
pendant de longues heures pour le
liquider ensuite à l'armé blanche sous
le fer noyé par les chiens
dans un étang et pour finalement donner
l'animal à manger aux chiens ce n'est
pas une chasse pour se nourrir près de
300 manifestants répondu présent à
l'appel de l'association abolissons la
vénerie aujourd'hui ils ont défilé au
son des tambours et slogan je trouve que
c'est vraiment débile on n'a pas besoin
de te dire animaux c'est pas des yeux
il faut que ça s'arrête pour dénoncer la
barbarie de la chasse à courre et pour
dénoncer à quel point ça n'a plus lieu
d'être
au 21ème siècle la chasse l'entente elle
me dégoûte pas ce qu'il ya de moins en
moins d'animaux en forêt parce que le
non-respect de la vie aux tambours ont
répondu les corps les pro chasse étaient
près de 400 pour défendre mon le milieu
rural on s'aperçoit qu'en fin de compte
il ya des gens qui sont pas de la
ruralité qui veulent décider pour des
autres et je trouve ça un peu dommage ça
fait toujours pratiqué la chasse à
courre rabon chatel ou alors voyez la
forêt de rambouillet le lieu de
chazelles équipages de bonnel
rambouillet depuis 1871
il faut savoir qu'un équipage de chasse
à courre c'est d'abord un élevage de
chiens et si on nous supprime on met nos
chiens qui sont le fruit de siècle de
travail disparaîtront avec nous c'est
une façon de maintenir le sauvage dans
les massifs forestiers
c'est à dire essentiellement éviter que
une belle forêt comme rambouillet
soetens tentant parc animalier et
finalement on dénature les animaux les
deux cortèges ont défilé sans se croiser
la chasse à courre a pris fin ce
week-end elle est autorisée chaque année
de septembre à mars selon un sondage
ifop de 2017 pour la fondation brigitte
bardot
84% des français sont opposés à la
chasse à courre eux étaient plus de
33000 contestataires selon la police
sont deux mille selon les organisateurs
samedi les gie les jeunes ont mené
l'acte vent de leur mobilisation dans
les yvelines ils se sont rassemblés
également dimanche l'opération parking
gratuit au centre hospitalier de
versailles pour dénoncer la gestion de
ce parking d'un équipement public par le
groupe vinci
les gilets jaunes ont interpellé les
visiteurs et distribué des tracts de
façon pacifique une façon de soutenir le
personnel médical et de rappeler leur
principale revendication c'était au
micro de nicolas landry les visiteurs
sont à peine arrivé sur le parking que
déjà ils ont ils doivent ils doivent
payer c'est ce que moi je considère
comme du racket
donc aujourd'hui on donne l'opportunité
aux visiteurs au pot patients qui
viennent se soigner de garder leur
argent et de profiter avec leur argent
avec leurs familles
on leur donne du pouvoir d'achat c'est
une façon aussi pour nous d'expliquer
aux gens
quel mouvement gilet jaune en termes de
revendication donc on distribue des des
petits fascicules en moi j'en ai un qui
est là qui est loric le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qui est extrême
extrêmement simple bien fait et qui
explique effectivement ce que l'on
souhaite à dos sur le rique législatif
révocatoire constituant et abrogatoire
tout simplement dans l'actualité aussi
la fin de la trêve hivernale dès
aujourd'hui les expulsions prononcées
peuvent être de nouveau effectué le gaz
et l'électricité aussi peuvent être de
nouveau coupé une situation préoccupante
pour plusieurs familles dans les
yvelines on en parle avec vous bernard
lions bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
responsable de l'antenne locale du
secours catholique à montigny le
bretonneux on va parler avec vous de la
fin de cette trêve hivernale mais aussi
de vos inquiétudes concernant des
campements de roms menacés d'expulsion
sur le secteur a déjà un mot sur le
secours catholique rappelons qu'elles
sont quelles sont ses missions vous
serez courir le seul intérêt de secours
catholique la com mission d'accompagner
des personnes en difficultés de tout
ordre social financier et humain et et
de parcourir avec le chemin qui est pour
qu'ils retrouvent une autonomie ou une
insertion dans le cas de ceux qui sont
un peu éloignés de la société ou
leurs prix se reprendre pied dans la vie
quotidienne donc c'est de
l'accompagnement beaucoup et votre
antenne locale et un rayon d'action
uniquement sur sur cette ville de
montigny le bretonneux comme comme il
existe des équipes locales sur les
communes voisines donc en fait on s'est
réparti les communes c'est un découpage
facile donc on agit sur la l'équipe
la commune de montigny sur ce sujet
d'aidés trêve hivernale est ce que vous
avez des familles à montigny concernés
par le sujet on n'a pas connaissance de
ce il ya quelques familles effectivement
qui viennent nous voir qui sont
éventuellement menacée d'expulsion
donc il ya éventuellement encore des
recours possibles aussi mais c'est plus
c'est plutôt effectivement la partie la
population qui n'est pas dans un et les
logements d'un parc locatif mais dans
des campements au bilan qui nous
préoccupe un peu justement pendant cette
période même maintenant maintenant
qu'elle est terminée quel est votre
travail comme comme association alors on
n'a pas vue directement pas beaucoup
d'actions possibles c'est plutôt dans
les phases où les personnes sont
stabilisés qu'on les accompagne une mère
va recherche d'emploi vers
l'apprentissage de la langue française
vers la recherche de logement social
l'apprentissage du français aussi la
scolarisation des enfants pour la la la
partie hébergement en cas d'expulsion
c'est plutôt de l'ordre des pouvoirs
publics de prendre sa recharge donc on
peut intervenir auprès d'eux mais pas se
substituer à une situation préoccupante
que vous souhaitiez mettre en avant
celle de trois campements de roms du
secteur qui sont visés par des arrêtés
d'expulsion prononcées par le tribunal
de versailles
combien de personnes sont concernées
alors le double de versailles ça
concerne je pense un des trois groupes
les autres ce sont des arrêtés
municipaux mais l'expulsion peut avoir
lieu que de toute façon il je pense que
ça concerne ma connaissance entre 40 40
à 50 personnes dans un rayon de trois
kilomètres autour de la gare de
saint-quentin
est-ce que des expulsions sont produites
dès aujourd'hui ou c'est prévu dans
l'ailé alors on ne sait jamais très bien
donc les
les autorités il faut que les préfets ou
les maires demandent le recours à la
force publique
donc ça peut s'étaler sur plusieurs mois
il ya une loi sur ces expulsions qui
date de 2012 qui a été complétée l'an
passé qui dit qu'en cas d'expulsion de
campements ou de bidonvilles les préfets
doivent mobiliser des dispositifs des
formules en tout cas d'accompagnement en
vue d'un excès possibles au logement
autonome c'est ça c'est et ça peut se
faire sous quelle forme cet
accompagnement effectivement majeur pour
rappeler juste que la particularité de
ces expulsions de campements par rapport
aux deux squats c'est que les personnes
concernées ne voient souvent pas d'autre
solution que de chercher un hébergement
de même nature à proximité et donc
d'année en année ça peut se perpétuer et
les mêmes personnes se retrouver
explique ses répétitions plusieurs
années de suite
alors que le texte gouvernemental auquel
fait allusion de janvier 2018
effectivement en juin en particulier aux
préfets de faire faire un bilan social
avant que les personnes soient expulsés
et de proposer avec les services sociaux
des formules d'hébergement pour les
personnes entrant on a constaté au cours
de l'année 2018 que sur les expulsions
connu à montigny ça ne s'était pas
produit comme ça les personnes sont
prévenues de voir déguerpir et le jour
venu sont mises devant
aujourd'hui vous permet de les sens
avant de dénoncer ça qui a pas eu
forcément de solution d'accompagnement
en tout cas pour les personnes qui ont
été expulsés l'année dernière
donc c'est ce que nous redoutons encore
pour cette année puisque on n'a pas
connaissance que les la préfecture qui
en charge de la chose
accorder des crédits et désigner des
intervenants sociaux pour s'occuper de
ça donc il ya un fort risque que ça se
produise de la même manière et certaines
des femmes des familles qui ont été
expédiés en 2018 c'était déjà la
troisième fois donc ça pourrait encore
être la quatrième fois la conséquence à
chaque fois c'est que les personnes dans
le général ont du travail où certains
les jeunes par exemple sont en cours
d'apprentissage du français ou
scolarisés
déracinement finale voire d'observer sa
case et d'un déracinement des
interruptions dans plus ce processus
d'insertion et un gros retour en arrière
qui peut faire perdre des mois et des
mois d'efforts de ces familles mais
j'allais terminer sur ça pourquoi c'est
primordial pour vous qui est cet
accompagnement c'est justement pour
favoriser l'insertion c'est ça cette
insertion absolument on s'aperçoit il ya
un organisme gouvernemental qui écorne
tous ces efforts qui fait de tentes qui
communiquent de temps en temps sur ses
réalisations on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des
bons cas il ya des villes où ça se passe
bien mais c'est toujours dans les cas où
la municipalité s'est emparée du
problème et en partenariat avec les
services sociaux les services de l'état
a décidé de traiter le problème en
faisant cet effort d'insertion et pas
simplement en se débarrassant des gens
dans les excuses merci à bernard lions
force et précision je rappelle que vous
êtes le responsable de l'équipe locale
du secours catholique à montigny le
bretonneux
nous sommes à huit semaines désormais
des européennes c'est le dimanche 26 mai
prochain à l approche de ce scrutin le
dossier de la rédaction est consacrée
cette semaine a lieu qu'elle soit
notamment les enjeux de ces élections la
maison de l'europe des yvelines s'est
penché sur la question une pièce de
théâtre était proposé la semaine
dernière au théâtre de saint germain en
laye le reportage de nicolas d'andré
l'europe à la barre des accusés avec le
public comme juré c'est le principe de
ce procès théâtralisée l'union
européenne est visé par plusieurs chefs
d'accusation les nombreux désaccords sur
les modalités de traitement de la crise
migratoire sont ils constituent des
motifs peur
dur du pacte européen blanc était
pénalement responsable de la situation
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons le
modèle européen au coeur du débat entre
la procureur et l'avocat de la défense
cette pièce participatif fait appel à
des experts des questions européennes
pour témoigner ce soir là rené pris au
conseiller municipal de saint germain en
laye et fanny du bre experts du cnrs
sont appelés à la barre
jégo question là créé en 2000 14 pièces
amène à réfléchir sur l'union européenne
à comprendre les mécanismes et les
décisions prises à ce niveau ainsi
certains enjeux des prochaines élections
européennes apparaissent il semblait que
la question du débat et aux européens
étaient trop polarisé les pro-européens
les anti européens et que le procès
était au final une très bonne forme pour
amener des nuances et de la
contradiction que pour nous l'enjeu
c'est de faire poser des questions aux
gens et de pas donné de réponse on passe
notre temps à écouter des réponses sur
l'europe ce qu'elle doit à ce que doit
pas être
nous ce qu'on veut c'est réinterroger
sur l'europe et l'exigence réintéresse à
ce sujet qui nous paraît primordial
autre enjeu du scrutin la participation
notamment des jeunes le député européen
jean marie cavada mobilise les lycéens
en tenant des conférences c'est le cas
du lycée marie curie à versailles avec
des élèves conscients des enjeux
européens
si si jamais les élections stopper la
construction de l'europe à part le fait
que des anti européens soit majoritaire
au pouvoir
alors comment serait un des siècles des
décennies en tout cas extrêmement
pénibles ou notion de petit pays à la
merci des grands et c'est ça que je ne
veux pas aussi un enjeu social pour le
bien être des gens l'évolution des
populations européennes et aussi pour
l'environnement qui va ne le cachons pas
très mal aujourd'hui j'ai une crainte
que le que l' influence du moment vienne
sur la sur le
européenne donc c'est pour ça que je
pense que le scrutin est important en ce
moment est aussi sur la raisons
climatiques qui est aussi extrêmement
importante c'est parce que c'est le
monde de demain
enfin ce scrutin aura un enjeu national
c'est la première élection depuis le
début du mandat d' emmanuel macron cette
échéance électorale dégagera un
enseignement politique dans un contexte
de contestation sociale menée par le
mouvement des gilet jaune l'école
scientifique des mines paristech va
s'installer bientôt à versailles et
trois de ses laboratoires sur le plateau
de satory vendredi le conseil
départemental des yvelines a approuvé la
construction d'un ensemble immobilier de
15 millimètres carrés laconique la
collectivité investit pour ce faire 70
millions d'euros un projet qui devrait
aboutir en 2023 après une tentative
avortée en 2013 les propos sont
recueillis par michael et demi d'euros
c'est à un moment absolument important
une pierre d'état puis le milestone dans
notre notre projet d'implantation à
satory
qui verra le jour en landau trois ans
maintenant et qui nous permettra de
regrouper trois laboratoires important
de l'école centre des matériaux le
centre d'efficacité énergétique des
systèmes et le centre de robotique sur
un site unique à satory c'est une
nouvelle remarquable pour l'industrie
yvelinoise qui a besoin de la recherche
telle qu'elle est portée par cette école
donc sonné dans ce cercle vertueux d'un
département qui fait des économies dans
ses dépenses quotidiennes pour pouvoir
investir dans des opérations qui vont
produire de la richesse et de l'emploi
en ce 1er avril nous ne pouvions éludé
le sujet de l'humour je vous invite
d'ailleurs à retrouver une bande annonce
de nos émissions une bande annonce
spéciale sur nos réseaux sociaux je vous
en dis pas plus
on parle également humour avec vous un
esata mini bonsoir vous êtes directrice
des affaires culturelles abus qui vous
est l'une des ambassadrices du festival
le rire soleil alors la deuxième édition
a démarré vendredi cinq dates une
dizaine d'artistes programmés et à
retrouver jusqu'au 11 mai la soirée
d'ouverture se dérouler vendredi à
rocquencourt il ya également une une
date à buc samedi est ce que cette
deuxième édition a bien été lancé
eh bien écoutez on est très content
parce que c'est une édition qui marque
la suite de la naissance du christ ivala
c'est toujours facile de faire naître un
festival mais de le faire de l'installer
passaient plus et que j'y suis donc là
cinq communes ont répondu présentes dont
but que pour la préparation de cette
édition qui
plus donc son ouverture se fait rare au
concours c'était une très très belle
soirée avec une un panel d'artistes
khlie qui effectivement est comme le dit
son nom rire et émerveillement puisqu'il
ya des artistes qui venaient de mongolie
donc franchement il ya pas que du rire
aussi de la musique de l'improvisation
un peu tout de l'improvisation du rire
de la musique
voilà c'était c'était vraiment un
événement qui rassemblait tout le monde
l'idée c'était de faire voyager les gens
et donc voilà avec le directeur
artistique et eric bouvron et qui est à
l'initiative de ce festival est donc on
le connaît aujourd'hui et il est plus à
présenter mais c'est vrai qu'il a
souhaité casser les barrières et faire
voyager les gens vous le disiez pâques
du rire c'est de l'émerveillement c'est
ça aussi le l'objectif plus global du
festival qu'on passe d'un univers à
l'autre et c'est très agréable
les organisant le rappel par
l'association rire 78 aussi
l'agglomération versailles grand parc à
une idée aussi c'est d'associer les
jeunes à tout ce temps de festival et
jeunes qui montent sur scène c'est ça
lors des premières parties des soirées
les jeunes du territoire
tout à fait c'est un festival qui en
fait un volet pédagogique important ça
c'est très important pour nous parce que
l'idée set fédérer aussi les jeunes de
les amener à à comprendre
en tout cas prendre part concept est
donc l'idée c'était de en amont du
festival monté des ateliers dans les
écoles on a choisi pour sa les écoles
primaires parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un âge assez intéressant et donc les
avec les artistes qui font partie de ce
festival qui vont aller dans les
différentes écoles travailler avec les
enfants sur les textes de vos ça sert
pour des enfants qui ne connaissent pas
forcément raymond devos les choristes
d'un autre âge mais qui al'avantage de
jouer avec les mots d'être un véritable
artiste en tout cas du mot complètement
et puis c'est surtout le ramener l'amour
des mots parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a du mal à faire lire
les enfants et donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de les amener vers l'amour des
mots d'une manière différente et donc
ils ont travaillé avec des artistes qui
viennent d'horizons
divers et ils ont restitué en fait ils
ont travaillé sur les textes de vos cils
les ont restitué d'une manière qui est
la leur et ça peut être du champ du mime
du théâtre voilà et donc samedi samedi
et vendredi on a vraiment une très très
belle surprise avec des jeunes enfants
qui étaient vraiment extraordinaire vous
disiez derrière tout ça il ya un homme
c'est eric bouvron
oui c'est eric bouvron qui est le
directeur artistique et après au niveau
de chaque ville c'est le service
culturel dont qui prend en charge de
l'organisation et des ateliers et puis
le l'organisation de l'événement en
lui-même alors et cette année il ya un
parent c'est le l'éditorialiste
politique journaliste christophe barbier
pourquoi le choisir lui ne fait pas
forcément le lien avec l'humour fait
sobre
c'est un choix qui a été fait par
l'équipe organisatrice du festival je
pense qu'il répond aussi à une attente
l'information l'envi de d'amener les
gens vers d'autres horizons donc voilà
et puis très gentiment il a été vraiment
très très impressionné par ce par ce
concept qu'il a souhaité soutenir et on
espère avoir un par un chaque année qui
pourrait porter ce festival et le faire
vivre
maintenant l'objectif c'est ça c'est le
nouveau didier en début d'entretien de
l'installer de le pérenniser dans le
temps et nous espérons tous cas je lance
un appel à toutes les villes pas
uniquement des yvelines mais d autres
justement de nous rejoindre et de et de
prendre part à ce festival voilà tout
est affaire tout est à construire
et le plus beau dans tout ça c'est que
s'est construit ensemble voilà on vient
pas avec quelque chose qui est déjà
posée mais on arrive dans chaque ville
on étudie les projets on essaye de
s'adapter aux besoins et en tout cas d'
amener quelque chose pour ceux qui ont
raté les deux premières datent pas de
panique il y encore il y en a d'autres
et les glandeurs nature ce vendredi à 5
avril à toussus-le-noble mikaël hirsch
le 13 avril à bièvres et enfin le 11 mai
à jouer en josas les frères coll
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
programmation comment elle s'est
construite la programmation c'est alors
la programmation faite à l'âme fil
conducteur qui est celui de
donc d'aller sur des sur des diverses
disciplines d'amener les gens à
découvrir donc vraiment de deyme de
passer un message aussi casser les
barrières fait rencontrer les gens
peut-être joué sur les préjugés sur et
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de balayer un
petit peu tous les to les comment dire
différents différentes différentes
disciplines différentes choses et puis
d'amener à les gens vers quelque chose
et vers la surprise aussi parce que
c'est vrai que de pouvoir ramener les
gens vers la surprise c'est sympa les
questions plus pratiques pour terminer
pour ses soirées on peut prendre
directement sa place sur le lieu de la
soirée ce qu'il faut réserver à l'avancé
tout à fait né sur chaque ville en fait
on s occupe de sa billetterie mais ça
aussi ça a étudié peut-être encore de
vallerand une billetterie commune pour
le festival ce serait sympa et les prix
des entrées on précise qu'ils sont de 5
à 12 euros voilà toutes les informations
bien sûr à retrouver sur la page
facebook du festival le rire soleil
merci anissa dlamini être patient sur ce
plateau directrice des affaires
culturelles dans la ville de buc moines
entre mon autre invité pour refermer ce
journal est un confrère bonsoir le roman
s'asseoir alors vous êtes le journaliste
au parisien yvelines et vous avez publié
votre premier polar mettez la au parfum
c'est aux éditions est hélas l'histoire
d'une spécialiste en lin ji en lingerie
fine dont la vie va se retrouver
bouleversé on aura l'occasion de pitcher
cet ouvrage dans un instant écrire autre
chose que des articles de presse est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui vous
trottait dans la tête depuis de
nombreuses années c'est quelque chose
que vous faisiez déjà si je vais loin je
peux dire que ça me trotte dans la tête
depuis que je sais écrire oui suffisait
de six mètres mais c'est pas facile de
s'y mettre et le trouver la bonne idée
et puis aussi de se nourrir de tout ce
qu'on a vécu tout ce qu'on tout ce qu'on
aime culturellement depuis de l'essayer
de ressortir quelque chose de sentir que
c'est le bon moment en fait c'était
compliqué est ce qu'il ya une différence
alors la question est peut-être naïve
mais entre la manière d'écrire un
article de presse et écrire un roman ce
qui a une différence il ya une vraie
différence c'est à dire que au parisien
savait qu'on écrit des articles courts
et nerveux
évidemment un roman ça se développe il
faut développer des idées faut
développer personnage après évidemment
être journaliste s'arrête de la
construction des phrases et des idées
la suite dans les idées mais après ce
premier polar qui a déjà un exercice que
vous préférez écrire des articles de
presse écrire un roman
j'aime bien les deux moyens extérieurs
emplettes ouais ça se complète au
journal on écrit dans l'urgence et puis
là on écrit dans le temps ou si le filet
de ce qui se passe dans la tête quoi et
vous disiez il faut avoir un déclic du
temps aussi comment on trouve le temps à
côté son activité professionnelle qui
consiste déjà écrire de trouver du temps
pour écrire autre chose
justement il ya quelque chose qui est
pas facile c'est à dire vous êtes vous
avez du temps il n'ya pas l'inspiration
alors vous avez l'inspiration vous êtes
en train de faire autre chose donc
le tout c'est de trouver le bon timing
et puis des fois de forcer aussi forcé
aussi d'inspiration et puis de revenir
après sur ce qu'on a écrit
éventuellement alors un petit pitch de
louvain je le rappelle un mettez la au
parfum l'histoire d'anaïs qui fait
carrière dans la lingerie fine que va
t-il se produire pour elle quelle est
l'intrigué salaires triste comme ça le
livre est drôle ça a l'air triste comme
ça sa mère meurt et lui laisse une
lettre en lui révélant le vrai nom de
son père qu'elle n'a jamais connu
il se trouve qu'elle découvre qu'elle
est l'héritière de la plus grosse
fortune de france puisqu'il lui reste
son grand père qui lui est vivant qui à
97 ans qu'il va bientôt passer la main
il mourir en tout cas elle va se
retrouver à la tête de la plus grosse
fortune de france et évidemment ça ça ça
crée des jalousies et des des jalousies
sa part peut-être vous lisiez d'une
nouvelle un peu triste mais finalement
il ya une idée de qui est aussi des
moments où drôle dans cette voie là je
pense que l' ouvrage est foncièrement
déroulerait d'accord reine du début à la
fin avec quelques moments d'émotion bien
sur mes skis mais en retour des gens qui
m'ennuie
ils disent qu'ils sont ils ont autant ri
que moi je vais gérer quand j'écris sur
les inspirations est-ce que vous puisez
peut-être alors les faits divers on les
yvelines sont sont nombreux est ce que
c'est une source d'inspiration pas du
tout ce qui a des auteurs peut-être qui
vous inspire sur les faits divers ça
peut être une source d'inspiration des
fois vont porter d'une brève et puis on
connaît les auteurs qui sont partis
d'une brève lu dans un journal local sur
ils ont écrit un livre non moi c'est
plutôt des auteurs est plutôt des gens
qui m'ont inspiré comme frédéric dard de
scott gnau et puis michel audiard ses
dialogues ses personnages décalés durant
l'escale pittoresque et j'ai lu que vous
écriviez sur un fond de musique vous
mettez de la musique pour écrire c'est
quelque chose qui vous motive à écrire
vous inspire également
c'est assez drôle d'ailleurs pas ce
qu'on écrit et puis tout d'un coup la
musique disparaît et puis tout à coup il
ya un mot dans la zone dans une chanson
qui revient qui vous interpelle enfin ça
marche comme ça pour moi est le seul mot
qui m'interpelle m'inspire une phrase je
laisse la musique en oeuvre et c'est un
polar vous avez présenté notamment aux
dédicaces et vous étiez au dernier salon
du livre comment c'était cette première
pour moi c'était assez incroyable contre
des gens à ne vendre son livre
de leur dire je vous promets vous allez
rire achetez le c'était faut être
convaincant et jean réussi à convaincre
quelques personnes
il y en aura d'autres et ce qu'il ya
d'autres projets en cours oui je suis en
train d'écrire le deuxième suit on va
dire aux tiers et puis j'ai déjà l'idée
du troisième donc le tout c'était
d'écrire le premier couac il ya eu
finalement qui va amener d'autres
d'autres ouvrages c'est ça il fallait
jusque il ya une petite fée de
l'inspiration qui me qui me pousse à
écrire celui là trouver l'éditeur
c'était pas facile je remercie max de
chez est hélas derrière et puis depuis
l'enfance est parti quoi donc ce premier
ouvrage qui est publié vous l'aviez aux
éditions est hélas mettez la au parfum
et c'est au prix de 9 euros 90 merci
laurent nan ça rentre ça sort fait aux
journalistes notamment aux parisiens et
biner auteurs maintenant de romans
polars et puis pas de chronique de
résultat dans cette édition
rassurez-vous mika l'ailier d'euros
arrive dans un instant avec son émission
le 7-8 sport score reportages et annonce
des événements sportifs
c'est toute l'actualité sportive a
retrouvé dans un instant voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]